here's a slightly more involved linear
equation we're asked to solve four and
here the variable is a and we have one
half times this whole expression three
times the expression five plus a minus
two is equal to a over two plus five
over two and it looks very daunting but
if we take it step by step we'll
actually see that it's actually a pretty
reasonable problem now maybe i'll take a
couple of stabs at it depending on how
much time we have so let me just rewrite
it once so one half times
three times five
plus a
minus two
is equal to a over two plus five over
two so one way that i could do it i
could start right over here i have this
three times five plus a i can distribute
the three so three times five is fifteen
three times a
is three a so i have 15 plus three a
so that's so this part of the expression
is this part right over here
minus two and then times that whole
thing times one-half is equal to and i
could also simplify this right hand side
right over here i have the same
denominator a over two plus five over 2
is a
plus 5
over 2.
and then if i simplify inside the
brackets i have a 15
minus a 2 so that will simplify to a
positive 13.
simplified to a positive 13. so again i
get a 3a
3a
plus positive 13 and then that whole
thing is going to be multiplied by
one-half and that's going to be equal to
a plus five
over two
now there's a bunch of ways that you
could go you could actually distribute
the one-half times both of these terms
right here but there's maybe a clearer
simplifying step and actually we could
have done this right from the get-go to
really have simplified our equation we
can just multiply both sides of this
equation by 2 in order to get rid of
this divided by 2 or this 2 in the
denominator so if i multiply the
left hand by 2 i have to also multiply
the right hand by two and then two times
one half is just one a plus five over
two times two is just a plus five and so
that simplified it a good bit we're just
left with three a
plus thirteen
is equal to a plus five and now like
always we want to isolate the variable
on one side let's isolate it on the left
hand side especially because we have
more a's on the left than we do on the
right so let's subtract a from both
sides to get rid of the a on the right
hand side
so let me subtract a
from both sides and i'm picking a to
subtract because i have an a on the
right hand side and i want to get rid of
all the a's on the right hand side
so i am left with on the left hand side
3a minus a is 2a
so i have 2a
plus 13 is equal to a minus a that
cancels out that's just 0. i don't have
to write down the 0. 2a is going to be
equal to 5. and now i really want to
have this 2a out here on the left by
itself so i want to get rid of this 13
so let's subtract 13 from both sides
so let's subtract 13 from both sides
these 13s cancel out on the left hand
side you're left with just a 2a
and then on the right hand side 5 minus
13 is negative 8.
negative 8 and then to solve for a i
just have to divide both sides by 2. i
have to divide both sides by the
reciproc by the coefficient on this a
i'm saying on the left-hand side 2 times
a is equal to negative 8. if i divide
both sides by 2
then i get a
is equal to
negative 4
and we are done and we could have
simplified it earlier on with that multi
multiplying both sides by 2. there's
actually many many many ways to do this
problem but just to show you how it
could have simplified it faster if i
multiplied the left hand side and then
the right hand side by 2 early on and
when you're multiplying this right hand
side by 2 remember the 2 has to be times
both of these terms on the left hand
side this would have just cancelled out
2 times 1 half is 1. so the left-hand
side would have simplified to 3 times 5
plus a
minus 2 and then the right hand side you
would have distributed this 2 2 times a
over 2 is a
2 times 5 over 2 is
5. and then you would have just kept
simplifying from here and you would have
gotten the same answer a is equal to
a is equal to negative 4. and let's try
it out just to have a little bit of time
let's actually verify that this actually
works if a is equal to negative 4 i'll
do it in blue we have the expression one
half
times three times five plus negative
four
minus two
it needs to be equal to negative four
over two plus five over two
every place that i had an a
every place that i have an a i replaced
it with negative 4.
so let's simplify this
5 plus negative 4 this simplifies to 1
so then we have
3 times one
minus two
so this is three times one minus two
this whole thing right over here
simplifies to
one
so you have one half times one the left
hand side simplifies to one half the
right hand side
negative four halves plus five halves
that's the same thing as negative four
plus five over two which is the same
thing as one-half so it all works out